hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from round 10 of the 2019
sinful cup it's another game that
features are not a very active piece by
nipple which were gonna see very very
soon so without further ado let's check
it out and then we're gonna fully
enjoyed the standings so an apple with
the white pieces open the width the red
it will Knight to f3 sorry about that
that was really really loud we have c5
by black inviting either to to a
Sicilian or two in English with c4 by
nipple and now Knight to f6 with nice to
see 3d five by black challenging the
century immediately seek after Sun be
590 after sandy 5 and now II four and
here nice to be four so what do you
wanna do here wood white Bishop to b5
check with night eight to c6 and now d4
just a nicely developing with C capture
son b4 and now a very nice pawn
sacrifice by Nippo a3 with D captures in
c3 Queen captures and d8 with check King
captors and e8 as the knight is pinned
and a capture Sun before and now C
character son b2 will the subchapter son
b2 and here f6 controlling the e5 square
black would very much enjoy playing a 5
here so the f6 should support e5 but of
course the neppo is not interested in
allowing that net approach is a five
himself and now Bishop to d7 with Bishop
to c4 by neppo preparing a six if you if
black makes a silly move like a 6 for
example then ISA just wins the game on
the spot now it doesn't really matter
what you do for example if you go back
up c8 then b5 is very strong you can't
capture as you're gonna lose the rook on
a 8 and if 97 then Bishop b4 going for
Bishop e6 and black really doesn't have
a move in this position there is a game
from 1979 Hans Bowen versus a young team
and versus Hans boom where BOM played
rook the c8 and the demon was able to
win that game but here we have a 6 by
Maxine not allowing of course white to
put e 6 himself and here nipple just
castles so e 6 was a new
in the position so as of move 13 we have
a completely new game nipple castles
into this and now Bishop to e7 with b5
by neppo asking what do you do with the
night there aren't all that many squares
the Knights can go to if you go to be
four then nice the d4 is very strong you
go after the e6 pawn so Maxime decides
to capture with Knight captures on e5
and now do you want to capture with the
knight or with the bishop neppo captures
with the bishop which seems odd you
really want to keep your bishop pair but
the thing is if you capture with the
night you get F captors and e5 and
Bishop captures and then Bishop to f6
and now for example you can either trade
or if you don't want to trade to improve
on black's pawn structure you can go
rook a d1 hopefully after a black
captures here you can win a pawn and
then win the bishop on d7 button black
will move with the King yet and now you
get rook F e1 a bushel captures on e5
rope captures and now after King t7 it
will be very hard for white to look for
anything more here then I draw even if
you win this pawn it's not a problem
let's say Rudy one you're just gonna go
rook 88 and now after let's say a trade
but shove captures a bit of characters
and rook captures you're just gonna move
the King and even though you do seem to
be more active than black black it still
has a very inactive look on a8 you can't
really trade rooks you have to move in
then black and really just trade one
pair of looks and bring the other into
the game if you trade then it's actually
black who's better here your King will
just pick up this pawn and then you will
use your King to control the King side
pawns while you're too connected fast
once on the Queen side should we need
the game so after Knight captures on e5
Napo decides not to capture with the
night as we will we've just seen that
you don't really have anything there and
as an echo is playing white here he
probably prepared for this Bishop
captures on e5 with F captures on e5 and
now rook F to D one first
there's always time to recapture first
you're gonna try and win a piece here so
King e8 you don't want your King on the
same file as white rook on d1 and only
now Knight captures on e5
bushra back to see it your Bishop is
under attack you can really move it
anywhere else so
bushra back to c8 and now b6 really
playing very actively here for for his
sacrifice pawn Knapp was really making
Maxine find some very very tough ideas
and a look at Maxim species here they
really aren't doing all that much so you
cannot capture of course as you would
lose the rook here the problem is if you
play a six this also doesn't work but
but it's a very nice idea so feel free
to pause the video and try to find what
the nipple had in mind had Maxine played
a six while I give you a couple of
seconds for those of you who were able
to do it congratulations you are an
excellent finder of winning ideas in
positions that never happened and for
those of you who just wanna enjoy the
show push up the b5 with check and now
there's a problem what do you do here
you can go to the defiled the rook
controls their the knight controls f7
you can go King f8 but now Bishop the a4
just getting the bishop out of harm's
way and black has no moves you can't get
the rook into the game you can't develop
the bishop to get the rook into the game
you can't get this rook into the game
you can't move the King so it's a sort
of a two-song not not not an actual one
but whatever you do you will ruin your
position for example if you try Bishop
g5 2 maybe 3 Dec 7 square for a king f4
just wins again
you cannot capture because rook f1 just
wins wins the bishop
you can go bishop to have sex but now
rook a c1 and you can never move the
King otherwise or if you capture here if
you capture the only five you get Rudy 8
checked and you win the rook on h8 so
whatever black does black really has no
move so this in fact if this happened
this would be like like like some sort
of a brilliant cook song that nipple
planned out but it didn't happen after
b6 of course maxime did not play a six
he of course saw that the Bishop to b5
was still a threat so he played Bishop
to c5 which makes sense you're ready to
recapture on a7 should white capture on
seven and also you're freeing the e
seven square for your King Bishop to b5
check this still goes tink the East
seven and here here is where the fun
really starts your nipple had a very
interesting idea
the Knight to c6 check and after B
captures the Bishop captures so a
temporarily sacrificed night where you
would either lose the rook or you have
to give back a piece by playing Bishop
to b7 and the game continues for example
if you try to save the room just a B
characters and a7 is better for white
you will either have to capture the pawn
or I mean you don't want to allow white
bringing a queen into the game you have
to move the rook so here you would have
to give up your dark square Bishop and
after rook captures white would you just
have a much better game but neppo did
not play Knight the c6 check as you've
seen from the thumbnail a thumbnail
never played Knight to d7 and it's a
it's a really funny move but it's funny
for a very specific reason it's funny
because it loses the game why closes the
game again feel free to pause the video
and try to figure out why in 90 d7 loses
the game while I give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations for
punishing such such a wild night move
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show Bishop to d6 and it
really makes sense I mean the knight has
no retreat squares the bishop now covers
the c5 squared where the knight actually
wanted to go in the first place it
covers the e5 and well there are no
other squares the pawn is on b6 so there
is no move for this Knight nepo finds a
way how to save the knight or you could
try giving away the exchange for example
King captures rook d1 check King moves
and then you can get the knight back
into the game but after I get person b6
you're down the exchange and also you're
down two points so black would be
completely winning here but neppo finds
an interesting idea on how to save this
night rook a to c1 and now the idea is
and this is well what neppo was hoping
for that if black just goes for the
piece right away then you play Bishop
character skin captures
and rook c7 check and now the bishop is
pinned you cannot capture it you have to
move the King King yet and now you win
back the piece and after eight captures
here you will play h4 and make some room
for your king and then you're gonna pick
up well the pawns here and have a much
better position where black still have
to figure out how to develop the rooks
so this was Nepos idea but after locate
to c1 maxime just played rook to b8 so
now a neppo has a retreat square for his
Knight but he's gonna be left with a
much worse endgame so nights the c5 was
played nipple hasta plate otherwise
you're just gonna lose a piece now
Bishop Tetris on c5 rook captures and e8
King captures and now rook captures on
c5 but now just a capture son b6 and now
you get this position where maxime is
just up two points in a po had a
brilliant position because he sacrificed
a pawn a very very active play but now
maxime just grabbed another pawn and now
you no longer have such a great position
but you're down two points look back the
c1 you have to guard against the
background mating ideas and then now
rook to a5 kicking away the bishop look
the b1 hoping to keep the bishop there
but now Bishop to d7 again you still
can't I mean you're not really gaining
anything if you trade a bunch of capture
screen capture so you cannot capture on
b6 or rook day one is again mate
so Bishop to d3 and now comes h6 not
allowing this capture we look after some
b6 now K you can retreat with the Bishop
Bishop to f1 it's possible and now comes
Luke to a 1 check Bishop to f1 and now
locate the rook is guarding the be 5
square so Bishop to b5 is not possible
King to c7 pushing the rook back so now
you're ready to start pushing your past
beep on we've looked a bit too and now
b5 now the King will start entering the
game f3 Knepper also has to start
bringing his King into the game King b6
we have king to f2 and now a bishop to
c6 with Bishop to c4 the pawn is pinned
here so you cannot capture the bishop
and now II five this pawn was being
threatened so here you just defend
the Shabak the d3 and now rook to a3 the
pressuring the bishop bishop back to be
one and now rook the c3 now the king can
also entered again via the C file or via
the a file and also the rook is
preventing the King from becoming more
active with King - E - and now rook the
sea for preparing rook to be for
preparing pawn to b4 from there while
the rugged offences from before King the
D - pineapple and now before with the
ship - a - and the now Ruby just moves
through d4 check with King to c1 and now
II for we have F characters on e4 rook
captures on e4 and now g3 whereas now
Bishop to b5 comes into play and now the
white king is you know really not all
that great there the the black King will
also join in and the pawn on b4 will
start going even further down the board
with King to d1 by nepo and now King to
c5 with rook to f2 but now Bishop to c4
Bishop to c4 is a very important move in
the in the sense of improving the
position because the bishop this Bishop
and pawn really create a nice wall here
against the black the white king and the
white king will never be able to
approach this position also you're
asking do you maybe want to trade
bishops of course white is not
interested in that Bishop to be one
attacking the rook rook to e7 with King
Tubby - and now rooked f7 offering a
trade and it was in this position that
yani Pony she resigned the game and a
very nice victory for maxime for
Sherlock Robb who I really don't think
he had any hopes of scoring a full point
in this game maybe he was hoping that he
could you know hold on to his passive
position and draw the game but - to be
awarded such a full point by nipple
playing Knight to d7 is just really
insane here okay we can play it out
after rook to f7 you you can go here the
bishop guards this square you can't
trade rooks otherwise the Bishop and
pawn endgame is winning for black as
black is up upon and you could go rogue
g2 for example but if this then just
King
before you're gonna go king c2 then
comes King III hoping for rook F to
check the trade rooks and after rubies
you want
still you get rook F to check King to c1
of course this wall is still here King
to c1 and now b3 whereas you can now
capture on h2 or if black does something
about it you're getting checkmate oh
sorry why does something about it for
example if you prevent the capture then
B to check you move the king and now
rook to e2 preparing the deadly Bishop
to b3
for example if Bishop to c2 blocking you
still get Bishop to b3 and now there's
no defense against a b-1 Queen the
bishop will be unable to recapture the
Queen because it's pinned and of course
if you capture then you no longer guard
the b1 square you can also grab a rook
since that is much nicer to checkmate
with less material but yeah now this is
a after this rook to have seven move
nipple resigned as there was really
nothing more to do here
so really insane idea and it's insane
how narrow is playing this tournament
the two losses came from Anand in round
one were he completely blundered in the
endgame it was an even bigger blunder
than this one I mean they're both
equally big since they both lose games
but I don't know the the one against
Anand just seems bigger but yeah other
than that you know still being up there
in the top after two such blunders
really really shows that whether it was
an exciting and great player Jonnie pony
she is and it's always awesome watching
all of his games so now you're gonna
understand the standings a bit more
there you have it Napo still with five
and a half points as he did going into
this game maybe you haven't realized why
this is so when we shall show the
standings in the previous video but yeah
it was gonna be gonna be really
interesting in the final round and we'll
see what happens if ding it's all up to
ding he has the white pieces against
mama D or if he wins the ding wins the
sinful cup if not then everyone has a
chance not everyone but obviously those
with 5 and a half points yeah that was
the game I do hope you enjoyed it
I would like to thank Jonathan Willis
Jarvis
all guests and Steve Kimmons for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it
as usual you can check - on my previous
video Sarah thank all for watching and I
will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the sinful
cup of the final round maybe we're gonna
even show it today continuing the
capablanca saga after that and of course
checking up in your suggestions and
we're gonna have a very nice puzzle we
haven't had a puzzle in a while so you
know stay tuned for that as well thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day